Linear networks are like
we mentioned before.
The learning rule is really simple for
those.
So that's great.
People [INAUDIBLE] Parr have
gotten cool things to happen for
things like cell phone, channel
allocation, and so that's pretty cool.
You have to be really, really
careful about what features you use.
Right?
because I probably
should have mentioned this before
the important thing about the features.
I'm going to say that it's important
that we find features that are both
computationally efficient and
value informative.
And what I mean by that is
computational efficient.
What would be an example of a feature
that is really really great but
is not particularly
computationally efficient?
>> The one that tells us what
the proper action is I don't know.
>> Or
what the value is actually in this case.
Exactly so.
So if there was a feature that
actually encoded the value function
that would be great.
That would be really good for learning.
The thing is we don't know how
to get that feature efficiently.
If we did we wouldn't
have to learn at all.
So we have to somehow get features
that we can extract efficiently from
the state,
but again that's really easy to do we
can just return the state as a feature.
It's really important that it
actually also be value informative.
So that one feature actually
gives you lots of information And
about what the predictive
value ought to be so
somehow balancing these two things
is often very tricky to get to work.
>> Right so going back to our taxi
example if it turns out that knowing how
far away the taxi is from some place or
how far away a passenger
is from some place.
And you can compute that pretty easily
then you should do it because it's
helpful and in your learning
are written as to figure it out so
that is really good thing, right?
>> Yes a distance to passenger could be
something that's both
computationally efficient.
because you can just kind of pull it
right out of the state representation.
And probably value informative because
it's actually very relevant to know,
are we close to being able
to pick up the passenger or
is the passenger quite
distant difficult to reach.
So yeah I think that's probably
the kind of things that we would want.
We probably should try that before
we tell people that we think that's
a great idea.
But in general these are the kind
of properties that you're trying
to balance.
>> Okay.
>> And I want to mention because this is
very hot right now another example
of using neural networks to learn
value functions has been carried
out recently by Google DeepMind and
they were using deep neural networks.
Do you know what deep
neural networks are?
>> Yeah, they're are networks
that are very profound.
>> Yes they're poetic neural networks.
>> Mm-hm.
>> No, they are neural networks that are
neural networks except some of them have
were instead of say three layers they
could have ten, 15 they can actually be
quite substantially more
sophisticated and complicated.
And they often involve using things
like convolutions to work well on
the visual kinds of inputs.
So what Minnetal all did at
Google DeepMind is they actually learned
effective strategies for
Atari video games mapping
the pixels on the screen to joystick
actions which is really neat.
>> It is
>> Right, so
it's actually learning to play the game
given very similar kind of input to what
people get.
And in fact they were able to get it
to learn very effectively to the point
where you could argue that it was
comparable to people on average.
>> At least on some games But did it
learn how to play thermonuclear war?
>> No, it learned that
the winning move is not to play.
>> Nice.
>> No, that's not true.
That was a WarGames reference, and
in fact, it did not learn not to play.
It was not given the option
to learn not to play.
It just had to play
whatever it was given.
>> Hm.
Grad school.
>> [LAUGH] And we're back.
No, it is true that, on some of
the games, it was superhuman, and
in other of the games,
it was way, way subhuman.
And that was why I said,
you could argue, on average,
that was about human level.
>> Mm, okay, but that's like arguing
that, on average, if I have my
head in an oven and my feet in ice
water, on average, I'm comfortable.
>> Yes.